on
calme relatif au gabon après deux jours
d'émeutes 150 français sont rapatriés
par le quai d'orsay vers paris
correspondance de notre envoyé spécial
menacés d'expulsion
foncez de sécurité de l'onu à genève il
demande des mesures d'urgence et des
sanctions contre israël
analyse du discours et reportages de nos
envoyés spéciaux sur les réactions à
jérusalem appel au dialogue entre
lituanien et soviétiques de la part de
françois mitterrand en visite éclair à
moscou face à michail gorbatiouk le chef
de l'état a évoqué la nouvelle europe en
construction
enfin le malaise de la justice française
congrès houleux du syndicat de la
magistrature et onde de choc de la loi
d'aministie radioscopie d'une profession
en prise avec le portait d'un jeune juge
d'instruction bonsoir le calme est
revenu au gabon mais c'est un calme
trompeur de nombreux français préfèrent
quitter le pays
plusieurs centaines d'entre eux
devraient arriver tout à l'heure ce soir
à paris quand aux journalistes étrangers
ils ont été pour la plupart expulsés nos
envoyés spéciaux
pierre babey et patrick milliers roues
ont réussi à rester
vous avez entendu pierre babey en direct
par téléphone à 19 heures ils étaient
confinés dans un hôtel de la deuxième
ville du pays port gentil il est il
toujours enfermés nous allons tenter
d'entrer à nouveau en relation directe
avec lui par téléphone caire et nous
sommes toujours à libreville pour
l'instant heures ne parle plus
d'expulsion pour ce soir et on attend de
pouvoir travailler dans le matin est-ce
que vous dire est que un autre 749 va
partir pour atterrir demain dans la
journée à paris et ils rapatrient rares
des français parmi les huit ans qui ont
été évacués de port gentil et qui sont
encore actuellement à libreville bien
rendez vous réussi à rencontrer le
président bongo
mais il est venu lui-même dans nos
prothèses a expliqué très longuement que
la presse française s'était livré à de
la véritable désinformation et qu'en
conséquence il n'était pas nécessaire
que nous restions l'on pense aux trop
folle mais pourquoi se montre-t-il aussi
intransigeant que s'est-il vraiment son
opposition
je pense que malheureusement elle sait
pas à quelle opposition il à faire cette
opposition est plutôt protéiforme
ce sont de véritables des votes
populaires qui ont incendié
mise à sac les villes de les rues de
port gentil est pour l'instant le
président bongo cherche plutôt à renouer
une forme de dialogue politique
alors qu'hier évidemment vous restez en
contact avec nous vous nous appelez à
tout moment au cours de ce jour là nous
savons que vous avez une interview du
président bongo nous espérons que le
satellite n'est pas coupée entre le
gabon et paris s'il ne l'est pas nous
aurons sans doute que les images de
votre interview au cours de ce journal
mais revenons à 10 sur les événements
d'hier de la nuit émeutes bâtiments
incendiés prise d'otages est clair et
manifestations la situation et hier et
avant-hier au gabon était proche de
l'insurrection selon certaines sources
des affrontements auraient fait deux
morts et plusieurs blessés libreville et
port gentil sont entêtés les villes les
plus touchées par cette révolte parfois
près violente
francine vraiment libreville l'image
d'une ville meurtrie après les violentes
émeutes d'hier et d'avant-hier qui ont
fait deux morts et 17 blessés
c'est un calme précaire qui règne dans
la capitale gabonaise depuis ce matin la
ville est quadrillée par les forces de
l'ordre
le gouvernement gabonais a décidé la
création d'une commission d' enquête sur
les circonstances du décès du leader
d'opposition joseph rendjambe dont la
mort a déclenché les graves désordres de
ces deux jours
mais l' incendie de l'hôtel où son corps
a été retrouvé et risquent de limiter
les investigations
une autre commission sera chargée de
déterminer les responsabilités dans les
actes de vandalisme et les
séquestrations des instructions fermes
et précises ont été données aux forces
de sécurité afin que l'ordre public soit
rétablie et maintenu le président omar
bongo a appelé les gabonais à se
ressaisir tout en réaffirmant qu'il
n'était pas question pour lui de revenir
au système de parti unique
en attendant de voir l'interview du
président bongo recueillis par pierre
babey écoutons le président gabonais nos
confrères de rfi ont réussi à lui
téléphoner ce matin ils ont recueilli
ses premières réactions écoutons le
est ce que vous vous posez des questions
aujourd'hui au moment de ces troubles
sur le multipartisme secte et de
français nous l'avons fait le point de
commencer
et vous vous dites qu'il faut peut-être
revenir en arrière je l'appréciais gt500
fait aujourd'hui la communauté française
qui vit en côte d'ivoire est également
inquiet des incidents se sont produits
avec une situation très alarmant des
incidents se sont produits ce matin aux
abords de l'aéroport d'abidjan et dans
le quartier de la présidence
des témoins affirment avoir vu des
policiers tirer en l'air et les
douaniers en grève ont bloqué pendant
une partie de la journée la rue
principale d'abidjan correspondance de
la sp audio sur place bernard nicolas
les douaniers ivoiriens ont déserté les
frontières et pour les cendres dans les
rues ils ont bloqué le port d'abidjan et
l'aéroport reste ouvert
ce sont les gendarmes essaient charge
des contrôles habituels des douaniers
réclame la militarisation de leur corps
avec l'espoir que cela va améliorer
leurs conditions de vie il réclame aussi
le départ de leur directeur général un
homme qui a récemment défrayé la
chronique en participant au lancement
d'un hypermarché qui vend les produits
importés à des prix imbattables
ils ont abondamment tirer avec leur
pistolet mais en l'air sans faire de
victime
le président félix houphouët boigny leur
a promis d'examiner leurs revendications
mercredi prochain comme il a promis
d'examiner celle des soldats d office
est des gens sérieux au regard des
pompiers
gardiens de prison les employés de la
poste et même celle des gendarmes
ceux là n'ont pas encore fait grève mais
il ne semble pas contre abidjan
bernard nicolas afp audio yasser arafat
réclame des sanctions sévères contre
israël il l'a fait aujourd'hui devant le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu réuni à
genève
joël hasard fort du succès diplomatique
que constituer pour lui la réunion
exceptionnelle du conseil de sécurité
yasser arafat a saisi l'occasion de
genève pour sensibiliser l'opinion
publique internationale
photos de jeunes palestiniens tués à
l'appui il affirmé que l'intifada est un
droit sacré tant qu'israël sera présente
en ces jours dany et gaza ces
propositions de meilleur urgents pour
enrayer la violence en cisjordanie et
gaza était déjà connu l'envoi de casques
bleus de casques blancs des nations
unies la constitution d'une commission
internationale d'enquêté sur la
situation des prêts m amiens des
territoires occupés des demandes
rejetées par avance par israël est en
partie par washington
reste la question de sanctions à
l'encontre d'israël et de l'arrêt de
l'implantation de colonies de peuplement
dans les territoires occupés le conseil
de sécurité pourrait devoir se prononcer
sur cette résolution
yasser arafat aura sans doute une
nouvelle fois convaincu les nations
unies la nécessité d'engager au plus tôt
des négociations de paix au
proche-orient mais ça demande réitérée
au conseil de sécurité de préparer une
conférence internationale reste un peu
plus de 120 corps israélien
comment réagissent les israéliens à ce
risque d'isolement de leur pays
reportage sur place de nos envoyés
spéciaux clément weill raynal et pierre
michel
vendredi veille de shabbat en israël
c'est un peu comme samedi en france dans
les rues de jérusalem cet après-midi
l'atmosphère était à la décontraction
dans quelques heures tout sera fermé le
pays tournera au ralenti
c'est dire si les italiens attache une
importance très relative aux discours
d'arafat à genève dont la presse
navières parler aujourd'hui
arafat aux nations unies il va encore
dressé le monde entier contre nous
explique ce jeune israélien
représentative d'une bonne partie de la
population
regardez cet enfant il a été gravement
blessé par une pierre jetée sur le
véhicule de son père mais ça personne
n'en parle
ce qui retient l'attention des journaux
du matin c'est la mise au point des
etats-unis définitive
opposé à l'envoi d'une force permanente
des nations unies dans les territoires
occupés position qui rejoint celle
d'israël
les américains ont relâché un peu la
pression estime la presse israélienne
les menaces américaines de ces derniers
jours sont interprétés comme un appel
pressant au premier ministre itzhak
shamir pour qu'il relance le processus
de paix dans tous les cas israël est
opposé à l'envoi de casques bleus dans
les territoires occupés une force de
l'onu ne contribuerait en rien un retour
au calme en cisjordanie et à gaza a
déclaré aujourd'hui le ministre des
affaires étrangères moshe harel
bien au contraire cela encouragerait les
actes de violence clément weill raynal à
jérusalem pour fr3 françois mitterrand
appelle les lituaniens les soviétiques
au dialogue lors d'une visite éclair à
moscou le chef de l'état rencontre est
michail gorbatchev pour un entretien de
plus de quatre heures au centre des
discussions la construction de la
nouvelle europe
reportage de notre envoyé spécial à
moscou s'il dit non c'est l'anxiété que
suscite chez les occidentaux la
faiblesse actuelle de l'urss fait
paradoxalement sa force
la preuve cette visite éclair
aujourd'hui à moscou du président
français cinq mois seulement après sa
dernière rencontre avec le numéro un
soviétique en décembre à kiev
il faut dire que l'optimisme d'alors a
cédé la place à une certaine crispation
chez l'actuel locataire du kremlin
la perte de l'europe de l'est a accéléré
la désagrégation de l'union soviétique
avec trois de ses quinze républiques en
état de sécession le tout sur fond de
crise économique et sociale sans
précédent
l'urss a également conscience qu'il lui
reste peu de cartes dans son jeu pour
empêcher l'allemagne réunifiée
d'appartenir à l'otan alors que faire
pour éviter que ne se développe en union
soviétique
un syndrome d'humiliation comparable à
celui qu'a connu l'allemagne après la
défaite de la première guerre mondiale
et qui fit le lit de l'anarchie puis du
nazisme
c'est particulièrement à cela que les
deux hommes ont réfléchi monsieur
gorbatchev a reconnu dans la conférence
qui a suivi que 70% des entretiens il y
avait été consacré ce fut l'occasion
pour le président français de relancer
son projet de confédération européenne
un projet fort précieux pour la russie
dans la mesure où elle ne se
retrouverait pas marginaliser repoussés
vers l'asie mais au contraire
entrez dans un continent qui est quand
même le sien l'europe
il ya déjà des structures dans
lesquelles les peuples de l'europe se
retrouve tous ou à peu près au sein de
l'association plus de pays extérieurs à
l'europe
continuant il s'agit pas de construire
en détruisant mais à mesure que le temps
passera les pays européens sentiront le
besoin de s'exprimer entre leur avenir
faudra-t-il avoir une rubrique racisme
dans nos journaux télévisés le nombre
d'agressions ou d'actes de vandalisme
est telle qu'on doit malheureusement se
poser la question à thonon les bains à
une cinquantaine de tombes ont été
profanées dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi et une église de la ville a été
saccagée croit arraché vitres brisées
les auteurs de cet acte n'ont toujours
pas été retrouvées et les policiers ne
dispose pour le moment que de très peu
d'indicés l'extrême droite et bien sûr
dans l'oeil du cyclone mais cela ne
l'empêchent pas de tenter de s'infiltrer
dans divers secteurs de la vie française
économiques culturels politiques bien
sûr et social c'est par exemple le cas à
l'université le cas de lyon iii est le
plus spectaculaire en quête sur place de
béatrice nivois et de philippe pons et
pas l'université jean moulin l'heure est
aux examens les étudiants pour un temps
oublier que l'un de leurs professeurs
bernard nota a publié un article
révisionnistes de procédure une
disciplinaire et une administrative
statueront sur son cas la fere notin
n'est pas un fait isolé et d'autres
enseignants à lyon iii sont liés de près
ou de loin
à l'extrême-droite rien de très choquant
pour le président de l'université
il est indispensable que les universités
quel qu'il soit ne soit pas
idéologiquement monolithique il faut des
universités diversifiée et puis faut
arrêter d'être d'étiquettes parce qu'il
ya deux personnes aux personnes de 10
personnes sur cinq ans qui relaie
l'information au banc des accusés le
centre d'études indo européennes et
celui de linguistique qui porte le nom
de son créateur un homme qui ne cache
pas ses penchants d'extrême droite
ces deux unités aujourd'hui déserts
fonctionnerait avec un budget
disproportionnée pour seulement 80
étudiants plusieurs enseignants de ces
deux centres appartiennent à divers
mouvements extrémistes certains voient
leurs écrits publiés par des éditions au
dessus de tout soupçon
les étudiants eux sont partagés bien
avant l'histoire ne tint qui a attiré
notre attention
l'extrême droite s'était infiltré dans
lyon 3 avec notamment de nombreux
enseignants tels que des membres du
conseil scientifique du front national
audry vial varennes hôtes un kiné qui
est censé ne plus y être depuis qu'ils
démontrent et donc avec dans l'actualité
c'est histoire de bernado tintin comme
par hasard au moment où on amnistie
votée à l'assemblée nationale ça arrange
certaines personnes ça permet d'éluder
certains problèmes et français en ont
marre des politiques
alors si la chasse aux sorcières qui est
ouverte ça permet de 10 ont dévié un peu
la contestation sur un professeur
invisible mais implantée l'extrême
droite le groupement union défense gud
officiellement disparu depuis cinq ans
de lyon 3 affiche toujours ses
convictions aux abords de l'université
comme il peut le faire dans 17 villes de
france de même que la troisième voie
mouvements extrémistes créée à lyon qui
s'est présenté aux élections
universitaires mais son succès la
justice française va mal et le malaise
est si profond qu'il s'exprime
maintenant ouvertement c'est le cas
depuis d'hier au congrès extraordinaire
du syndicat de la magistrature centre et
ce n'est pas un hasard sur le délicat
problème des rapports entre la justice
et le pouvoir une fièvre aggravé on l'a
vu par l'ondé de choc de la loi
d'aministie diagnostic d'une profession
en crise établie par un jeune juge
d'instruction portrait signé hans
rongeurs et christian de carnets
khater c'est ici qu'a atterri françois
perrin il y a quatre mois notre petit
juge
il a 26 ans sortait tout juste de
l'école juvénile et déterminé il navigue
depuis de déceptions en découvertes
avant j'étais contre le port de la robe
je pensais que la justice était rendue
par des hommes
et puis j'ai compris que rendre la
justice était un peu autre chose que
rendre une décision
il y avait quelque chose un peu sacré
qu'il y avait un rituel qui avait tout
un cérémonial et que le port de la robe
faisait partie un peu de la fonction
symbolique qui exercent un magistrat la
déception
l'envers du décor la pauvreté de dame
justice trombone et agrafeuse en sont
les deux mamelles ironise françois
pérain manque d'effectif manque de
moyens un exemple kafkaïen les archives
cet endroit est hautement symbolique et
est symbolique de la l'engorgement de la
justice autre surprise de plus en plus
d'affaires de drogue
en fait c'est dans le silence feutré du
palais de justice que ce joyau huit clos
les drames d'une ville apparemment sans
histoire une affaire sur deux traités
par françois pérain concerne l'inceste
il ya la loi du silence il ya donc il
faut un peu lutté contre contre ces
pesanteurs il faut essayer de faire un
peu parler les gens et surtout faire
bouger les choses et faire en sorte que
l'inceste ça soit pas à tabou une
justice sans tabou un point crucial pour
françois perrin qui a vécu une amnistie
comme un électrochoc un malaise discret
secret mais profond un malaise partagé
par beaucoup du de sa génération les 30
40 ans représentent les deux tiers de la
profession des jeunes qui trouvent leurs
aînés trop tiède dans leurs critiques
j'espère que je n'attendrai pas l'agent
retraite pouvoir connaître une justice
digne d'un pays démocratique c'est à
dire une justice indépendante
quelle légitimité de cette justice
d'une justice qui s'exerce au quotidien
qui s'exerce de manière sereine et
séduit 6 pour les affaires qui c'est qui
s'exerce de manière exceptionnelle et
qui est soumis à de multiples pressions
portrait d'un jeune homme en colère qui
malgré tout dit il a toujours le feu
sacré pour combien de temps laurence
piquet résume les autres événements du
jour couverts par notre réseau régional
laurence piquet tout de suite les
contrôleurs aériens de l'aéroport de
nice suspendre leur mouvement de grève
prévu ce week end le directeur de la
navigation aérienne s'est engagé à
résoudre rapidement les problèmes
techniques de la tour de contrôle de
nice
mais attention l'ensemble du trafic et
rien ne pourra être rétablie
progressivement
un professeur dit lutter de nancy
suspendue par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
motif il avait proposé lundi à ses
élèves un exercice de comptabilité
utilisant des factures au nom fictif
d'un monsieur juifs d'une madame
antisémite
le tout libellé au nom d'une société
carpentras exercice qualifié de
scandaleux par le rectorat l'enseignant
pourrait être révoqué
une flotte si britannique de 80
embarcations a fait son entrée hier dans
le port de dunkerque célébration du 50e
anniversaire de l'opération dynamo
en mai et juin 1940 ces petits bateaux
avaient réalisé la même traversée de la
manche pour évacuer les soldats
britanniques et français bloqués sur les
plages de dunkerque
enfin 2600 sportifs handicapés mentaux
réunis à liévin ils vont disputer
jusqu'à dimanche les jeux nationaux du
sport adapté
quatorze disciplines représentées la
fédération française de sport adapté
compte plus de 450 clubs et 100000
pratiquants
elise lucet tiens à vous présenter la
page sports de ce 19 à commencer par le
football paul ce soir au parc des
princes marseille affrontera le racing
en demi finale de la coupe de france
l'om déjà champion de france et le grand
favori face à une équipe en pleine crise
hier soir hier soir à saint-etienne
montpellier s'est déjà qualifiée pour la
finale de la coupe de france face aux
stéphanois s'étaient bien à
saint-etienne caroline sièges
le héros de cette fantastique demi
finale eric cantona sa définition du
match il y avait tout le public
l'orage le suspense trois ingrédients
auxquels il faut ajouter le talent de
l'avant centre montpelliérain auteur du
seul but de la rencontre un but
somptueux
37e minute de match le mou écarte le jeu
pur jus et rêve qui tellement sûr de
trouver cantona au deuxième poteau sans
trop sur lui sans même lever la tête
cantona est bien là et sur une reprise
fulgurante ir dans l'en but stéphanois
le gardien des verts ciccarelli
remarquable tout au long du match n'y
peut rien l'ambiance monte alors d'un
cran dans le chaudron surnom du stade
geoffroy guichard et les verts partout à
l'attack en deuxième période
sous une pluie diluvienne malgré leur
supériorité numérique après l'expulsion
de valderrama et deux superbes occasions
ils ne pourront jamais marqué ici
mendy seul devant les bus va tirer sur
le gardien
dernière possibilité raté
montpellier qualifié pour la finale nage
en plein bonheur le président nicolas
ans mort même son entraîneur éric à huit
chances sur 10 le reste est
montpelliérain effectivement parce que
ça c'est une promesse
et c'est vrai que pascal méthode je le
verrais bien les bus de montpellier je
crois que pascal serais très heureux de
signer à montpellier
les stars du racing quitte le navire le
malheur du rp un fait le bonheur de
montpellier le racing qui descend en
deuxième division recherche des fonds
désespérément parce que c'est
aujourd'hui une nécessité pour un club
formateur de vivre plusieurs années on
ne fait pas une formation en six mois ou
un an
il fallait une aide une reconnaissance
de la ville de paris certes limité et
j'ai demandé officiellement 7 millions
de francs ce soir l'om devrait
facilement se qualifier face au rpr et
jouer la finale contre montpellier qui
pourrait de ce fait disputer la coupe
des coupes
quand la cliente et nice à trois jours
du début du tournoi des internationaux
de france à roland garros les tirages au
sort ont eu lieu ce matin un tableau
final plutôt favorable aux français à
l'exception de leconte qui rencontrera g
nord au premier tour difficile en
revanche pour les françaises sauf pour
nathalie tauziat et nous allons revenir
sur la situation au gabon où la
communauté française est importante il
ya près de vingt mille personnes dans ce
pays je vous propose d'écouter le
témoignage de français vivent là bas
il s'agit du directeur technique de la
raffinerie elle à port-gentil
témoignages recueillis par claire
sébastien
le directeur a pris un gradé d'après ses
dires il ya eu pas mal de choses est-ce
que les looks l'epim les pilleurs s'en
sont pris aux locaux de la raffinerie et
de la société
est-ce que vous continuer à fonctionner
à l'heure qu'il est nous allons
retrouver en direct du gabon par
téléphone évidemment pierre babey pierre
caire vous m'entendez alors est ce que
vous êtes toujours enfermé dans un hôtel
de libreville pierre oui tout à fait
pour l'instant où les choses se passent
quand même plutôt bien puisque
l'atmosphère est relativement calme les
familles sont regroupés dans des hôtels
proches de l'aéroport et les dernières
d'entre elles devraient quitter le sol
gabonais demain matin 7 heures à bord
d'un vol spécial est-ce que vous avez la
chance éventuellement de sortir de votre
automne pour aller signer alors pour
l'instant nous avons déjà pu récupérer
le matériel
c'est un énorme progrès par rapport à la
situation de ce matin et le n'attendons
maintenant du ministère de l'information
l'autorisation de tourner à l'extérieur
est-ce que vous pouvez rassurer les
familles des français qui vivent au
gabon
ces incidents ne sont pas déroulées dans
les quartiers français aucune perte de
vie humaine inauguré à déplorer et pour
le sens le calme en tout cas règne à
libreville et pour port gentil nouveau
point d'information en facilement des
cultures sécurité alors nous dit que le
chef de l'opposition qui est mort le
corps de celle d'une opposition devrait
être rapatrié demain port gentil est ce
qu'il ya un risque d'émeutes en sommes
au caire pour la sauce est tout à fait
plausible
les mouvements font évidemment
d'information le corps de josé président
d'ettore partie ce soir même
dieu mais nous n'avons pas pu assister
la semaine nous mêmes merci faire baver
on vous retrouve évidemment dans soir 3
présenté par marc hautement et à 20h35
thalassa le magazine de la mer
bonsoir
juppé